hey guys it is the 29th of much today my
name is Jess and here's some gaming news
it looks like the critically acclaimed
middle-earth shadow of Mordor could be
getting a sequel nerve leaks have
uncovered the online resume of
stuntwoman Lauren Mary Kim who listed
that she worked on shadow of Mordor to
underneath the motion capture category
Kim previously did motion capture for
the recall III trailer and Murphy 3 it
also lists that the work was done with
blur which likely refers to blur studios
the animation studio who worked on halo
the master chief collection and sunset
overdrive along many others develop a
monolith has not released an official
word on whether a sequel is in the works
flat paws robot heavy automaton DLC has
been followed up by the launch of
survival mode on pc today you can get
survival mode on steam by opting into
the beta Bethesda have said they hurt
the ultra challenging mode forces
players to make interesting choices
supposed to say survival mode will
intensify strategic decision making slow
down the pace of exploration encouraged
clever resource management by balancing
widely available item and increase the
realism of just how shitty the
post-apocalypse is quick saving and
almost all auto saves are disabled
you'll now need to find a bed to sleep
in to save fast travel is disabled you
deal and take more damage threats won't
show up on your compass you need to
worry about eating drinking and sleeping
properly and fatigue will affect how
many action points you can use you can
check out the full list of features plus
a bunch of pictures that have arrived in
a new patch in our story on gamespot
finally call Judy 2016 is taking on the
final frontier lab soup reports from
Eurogamer and neo gas proved to be
correct industry insiders shinobi posted
on NeoGAF claiming the upcoming call of
duty will be sat in the very fast future
featuring space combat and also threw in
the phrase of full on syfy Eurogamer is
backing up this description with things
they've heard
from their sources although it's too
early to say whether we're looking at an
entire game set in space or just a
portion like in the opening section of
2013's call of duty ghosts call Judy
2016 edition is going to be developed by
infinity ward and has been described as
innovative infinity would discuss the
possibility of a call of duty set in
space back in 2013 at which point they
noted there would be a lot of the
mechanical challenges to overcome let me
know down in that comment section if
you'd like to see call of duty be set in
space and you can have two gamespot well
we've got stories on killer instinct
running at 60 frames per second and how
to get cheap metal gear solid games that
is everything I have for you today as
always let me know what matter to you
and I will see you against more